[Music]
welcome to day three round five of the
2012 Chess Club Invitational we're
starting to see some players be
mathematically eliminated from being
able to achieve their GM and IM norms
today we're gonna look at two games from
the IM section of this tournament LaVon
burg as he only had kind words for his
opponent Deckard after their game was
over regazzi remained in the lead here
in his section I have to say that my
okay
I was having a good tournament and he
played really well the last tournament
having Thanksgiving open so I was help
point up and maybe draw was also good
for me so I played kind of defensive so
this is really hard to hold with white
and another mistake I think was rookie
too because he has to maintain two loops
on the board to to keep chances to draw
and I don't think rookie two was a good
move because then I have really easy
play just take the rook a four and put
upon so what happened in the game is
that I mean this is all force and I
missed the stalemate idea here like
after g6 I thought I was winning easily
like G takes a 5g takes a five king
gauge for King b3 Rock a one and A two
king h5 group and rook a six I thought
he was winning but then I found a
stalemate idea like H for King b2 rook
takes a two King takes a two and a six
I think this position I taught you this
question was draw I haven't analyzed the
at least with the engine but I didn't
really like this this ending so I also
missed a good move rook a4 here and then
King h5 would takes a for King takes
eight six rookie for King g5 rook if I
and probably this is wonderful ACK
so in the game a to King age five can be
to King a to King g6 I know this is this
is one so it was a tough game and I'm
really happy that I won after five Tommy
all work is still able to clinch a norm
while FM's kaputski and home I have it a
little bit tougher they must win every
game from here on out
indeed Seth Homa did take some risks
that did not pay off today in his loss
to Ana sure a [ __ ] I really really had
to win I thought in this round and my
next round to have a chance at an IM
norm so I was pretty much taking a risk
by going into position I didn't feel
really comfortable in but you have to go
for broke sometimes not what do what not
what you want to have to calculate when
you go on time so I played Queen b3
pinning the night sort of threatening b7
maybe so now if I take on e4 its Queen
g6 is in a pin but she simply plays King
h8 I don't think I can take that pawn I
take c4
whoops Queen g6 is the move 92 and I g3
do this to the I take steep the Queen
takes you to be okay 8
like it to Queen G to rook F one after
simply rekha-ii
she has really really strong pressure
here I can't really Castle queenside I
don't think because after f2 goes III is
also really weak so at this point I was
getting really short of time I now had
after this move I had 13 minutes to make
20 moves so I thought the safest
continuation was taking on d5 at this
point I'm forfeiting all hopes for
advantage I'm just trying to survive
until loop 40 Darwin yang made a mistake
today in the GM section against Vita
lien Emer allowing the game to be drawn
and Nemer sitting at the top very happy
with 4 points
rounds are 11:00 a.m. and 5:00 p.m.
every day through Friday watch the games
live at st. Louis chess club dock organ
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]